dernier tour de chauffement pour Andy
ensuite c'est l'Open contest les 18-35
ans frissons assuré sur la compétition
ils ont le droit à un tour et il
finalise par le dernier tremplin ce qui
leur permet d'exécuter une grosse
dernière figure sous les
applaudissements de la foule et de
proposer le meilleur domaine non
seulement pour s'amuser mais pour aussi
mettre des points et se qualifier pour
la finale cet après-midi
heureusement pour Andy la météo est
estivale aujourd'hui
[Musique]
sur le lac pierre enchaîne les figures
et vu d'ici le rider semble être aguerri
pourtant j'ai commencé à
m'intéresser vraiment m'appliquer cet
été en début d'année en 8 ans le câble a
changé la vie de paulini aujourd'hui on
vient de loin pour se téléski nautique
et les champion locaux se multiplient on
y parle même une drôle de langue
oui oui oui ça coupe le rail écrite bien
replaqué et là ça soit le mur les gens
de la région se sont bien mis au sport
de glisse au départ on craignait qui est
pas à l'esprit glisse et finalement
finalement être réglisse est venu très
vite et donc on a tout un tas de jeunes
qui progressent bien on organise chaque
année un petit événement donc cette
petite compétition les premières années
c'était en interne et puis depuis l'an
dernier on l'ouvre des pratiquants
d'autres régions et d'autres téléski
toutes les générations sont là sur l'eau
mais aussi tout autour
de mes enfants qui admettent mes petits
fils a découvert ça l'année dernière et
il viendra aider et tout se passe bien
ils adorent ça le téléski nautique est
électrique il ne pollue pas écoute
beaucoup moins cher à utiliser qu'un
bateau le spectacle est impressionnant
il faut juste nager un peu en cas de
chute pour regagner la rive